it's been a year and a half since
appease deal was agreed for Myanmar but
little progress has been made
the internal divisions within asean
never allowed the process to go forward
and number two the support from China
Russia and to less sex than India also
contributed to strengthening the Junta
in Myanmar while Russia has been vocal
about its support for the military
rulers a report published by a group of
international legislators says China's
support which mostly happens behind
closed doors has also undermined asean's
capabilities
myanmar's Junta reportedly uses Chinese
and Russian supplied weapons to launch
attacks on its citizens
one human rights lawyer says
understanding how the military works is
key to resolving the crisis
it comprise his
holy of the Obama ethnic group combined
with the Buddhist religion this needs to
be understood by the International
Community that they are not dealing with
a national Armed Forces they are dealing
with a rogue ethnic armed organizations
that has loaded over the other ethnic
groups for so many years
rights Advocates and diplomats say it's
time for asean to look beyond the peace
agreement and engage directly with
myanmar's Shadow government made up of
opponents to military rule or even
engage with those outside the block it
might be in good advice to bring other
countries on board other countries who
have had success in Bridging the Gap
between various various conflict
situations like Norway for example
bringing the U.N for example into the
process to help speed up the process
one thing is clear the crisis has to be
resolved and soon
this plays out into the possibility of
Myanmar
becoming a new
area of great power rivalry
Russia China
seeking access to the Indian Ocean
that just spells the disaster for
Myanmar
and the whole of asean
aside from the broader geopolitical
consequences the UN special Envoy for
Myanmar has warned the conflict has
already taken a catastrophic toll on its
people
Florence Louis Al Jazeera